welcome back to cbs this morning we have
a follow-up on a cbs news investigation
from last year it's a very disturbing
issue
child abuse suspects in this country who
fled to israel
now one of those suspects his name is
gershon kranzer was returned to new york
city just yesterday to face the charges
after more than a decade in israel he is
accused of molesting
two female relatives one of them was
just six
years old at the time ian lee has
investigated these cases for years and
his reporting
has had a major impact he joins us now
from london with more on this story ian
good morning to you
good morning gail people like kranzner
exploit a process
called the law of return whereby any
jewish person can
move to israel and automatically gain
citizenship our investigation last year
revealed how this loophole
has allowed dozens of accused and
convicted american pedophiles
to flee there you know he's six foot two
over two this was our stakeout in israel
in 2019
looking for jimmy carro an american
wanted for sexually assaulting multiple
children
yeah yeah that was him that was
definitely definitely him oh my god
police arrested him after 20 years on
the run
did you assault the girl in the united
states
did you flee israel because you
assaulted the girl in the united states
do you know that you're wanted by
interpol
this arrest was for a rape in israel but
our report
broke the news of cairo's arrest to one
of his alleged victims in america
casey meyer smith how did you feel when
you saw the video
of police leading him away
thankful because at least i had
that video to show me
i i wanted to see that gotcha moment
for so long but also i was even more
angry
because he denied what he did to me
casey and her twin katie were just nine
years old when they met cairo at their
neighborhood pool in clackamas county
oregon
he would make
jokes and um start
uh poking fun at us playing games with
us and then touching us and grabbing us
and getting us closer and then he
sexually abused me and my sister
um repeatedly what happened next when
you went to the police
i remember we had
exams as children
i remember that we also had grand jury
cairo fled before being indicted but no
one told casey
for years she thought he was locked up
case closed
i found his name on clackamas county's
most wanted
that must have been a shock to you yeah
very frustrating do you feel let down by
the authorities
yeah casey then began her own search
eventually tracking him to israel i
found him he had found his work
even and i sent it to
clackamas county it took another seven
years before she saw us follow shawna
aronson
and her team from the organization
jewish community watch
track hero down south of tel aviv she
immediately reached out to shauna
they were so grateful that there was
somebody out there that had been looking
for him
and that actually that cared about this
soon after our investigation
aired israel changed its policy now
requiring immigrating americans to
undergo
fbi background checks this was a really
important step not enough to close all
the holes
because there are so many people that
can get through you know through other
ways and through other means and and
there's certainly other efforts that are
needed
but this was a very significant step a
significant
step to stop people like caro who last
month was sentenced to 13 years in
prison in israel
for raping a child
casey and her twin katie now want carol
extradited to the united states to face
justice
for what he allegedly did to them and we
reached out to the district attorney in
charge who told us that
they're diligently working with u.s
authorities to get cairo back but
ultimately it'll depend if israeli
authorities will hand him over
and that's not necessarily a done deal
anthony all right
do we and do we know why he was walking
with a limb
well he had a medical condition and this
was actually crucial to finding out
where he was going to be and
able to arrest him the jewish community
watch was able to learn that he was
going to be at that hospital dealing
with that issue
and that's where they were that's when
they were able to notify police
all right ian lee in london thank you
ian